Russia says this is the aftermath of a
Ukrainian drone attack in Moscow the
attacks on the capital have residents
concerned
I don't know when the explosion happened
but the security team was great and came
to our apartment and asked us to go
downstairs
here you can see Emergency Services
working at one site of a Down drone
Russia says it will find those
responsible
the emergency services are working on
the ground investigators and forensic
experts are also there the perpetrators
of this crime will be identified drone
attacks deep inside Russian territory
have intensified in recent weeks on oil
installations and even the Kremlin which
blamed at Ukraine for that attack Kiev
denies any link to the attacks and does
not comment publicly on the drone
strikes
but Ukrainian authorities have been
speaking about attacks on its territory
the mayor of Kiev of Italy Klitschko
says the latest wave of drones to hit
this city was a massive attack it's it's
sterile it's genocide the drones hit the
southern part of the capital at night
the attack came after a barrage of
missiles at Kiev in an unusual daytime
attack
when the drone's flying there is fear
now we are happy we are alive
the city's residents are now resigned to
living with what was once unimaginable
Imran Khan Al Jazeera